[Music]
hey true believers Lorraine Cink here
and the Marvel minute is back we're
going to be bringing you the latest and
greatest Marvel news each and every week
so let's get into it you may have
noticed I am the hood in the office I am
on the red carpet for Marvel Studios
Avengers infinity war in theaters on
April 27th I'm here in LA we just
finished meeting all of the amazing cast
members it was awesome to hear what an
amazing time the cast had working on
this film and if you want to see all of
the action you could check it out with
clips on marble comm I am just dying to
see this film are you guys excited well
the good news is is that you don't have
to wait much longer Marvel Studios
Avengers infinity work comes out this
Friday if you haven't grabbed your
tickets yet you are definitely gonna
want to do that because you are really
not going to want to miss this and in
addition to all of this movie madness
Marvel Studios have been releasing
celebratory content for the 10th
anniversary there was the Marvel
Cinematic Universe 10th anniversary
exhibit which we explored with Langston
on the red carpet but they've also been
releasing behind the scene photos from
the past ten years of Marvel films keep
an eye out for more ways that Marvel
Studios is celebrating with its fans and
that was your minute of Marvel news see
you next time
[Music]